tu vas commencer ta recherche après
avoir trouvé son objet d'étude tu as
posé une question de départ qui t'a
permis de filtre et et lecture est de
trouver des éléments de réponse tu as
bien sûr organisé ces éléments en
différentes problématiques et il te faut
maintenant on choisir une je m'appelle
sylvain dramé je suis enseignant
professeur en sciences sociales dans le
secondaire en belgique et dans cette
vidéo je te donne les clés pour choisir
la meilleure problématique pour ton
travail
je pense qu'avant de commencer on peut
rappeler ce qu'est la problématique
selon le manuel de recherches en
sciences sociales de raymond qui vit luc
van campenhout et pour la cinquième
édition jacques marquet il s'agit de
l'étape 3 de la démarche des sciences
sociales définissent la problématique
comme la proche où la perspective
théorique à adopter pour traiter le
problème posé par la question de départ
autrement dit l'angle sous lequel les
phénomènes vont être étudiées et il peut
y avoir plusieurs problématiques
envisageable ça tu leur as sans doute
remarqué lors de tes lectures il faut
donc bien choisir et ce choix est
d'autant plus important que la qualité
générale de ton travail dépendra en
grande partie de la pertinence de cette
problématique et oui je te met la
pression mais comment faire je vais donc
maintenant te proposait sept types de
problématiques qui peuvent se révéler
être très intéressante pour une
recherche et donc de bons choix pour ton
travail pour cela je me base sur
l'article d'andré gosselin intitulé la
notion de problématiques en sciences
sociales tu trouveras évidemment toutes
les références dans la description de la
vidéo ea fin de la vidéo je te dirais le
type de problématique le plus courant
dans les différentes recherches de
sciences sociales si ce n'est pas encore
fait je t'invite à d'abonnés a leaké
cette vidéo cela fait plaisir et c'est
en quelque sorte un petit peu mon
salaire lors de l'exploration tu as
remarqué que parmi les différents
travaux portant sur un phénomène un type
d'explications étaient manquants et
qu'il n'y avait pas forcément beaucoup
d'informations sur cette problématique
par exemple je me souviens avoir cherché
il ya quelques années des données sur le
lien entre la détection de la dyslexie
est l'origine sociale et j'avais été
surpris de ne pas trouver grand chose
sur la question est bien là
constituerait très certainement une
excellente problématiques de recherche
car l'absence ou la rareté de
connaissances sur un objet augmente
l'intérêt d'une recherche mais quand on
débute en sciences sociales c'est
peut-être compliqué de se lancer sur
cette piste car par définition il y aura
peu d'informations à trouver et ce n'est
pas toujours évident de dénicher ce
genre de perspective étant donné la
multitude de connaissances nouvelles qui
émergent chaque année sais tu que tous
les huit ans la masse des travaux
scientifiques double par as il dès lors
de dégoter des thèmes inexplorés
certains phénomènes sociaux ont été
tellement travaillé qu'on ne peut
presque plus rien apporté de nouveau
mais parfois une nouvelle approche une
nouvelle façon de faire permet de
renouveler complètement une thématique
récemment j'ai lu un article sur la
mobilité sociale qui est un thème très
travaillés en sociologie d'ailleurs si
tu tapes mobilité sociale dans le moteur
de recherche qui obtient plus de 118
millions de résultat dans l'article en
question l'auteur cyril jahier aborde la
mobilité sociale de manière tout à fait
nouvelle en utilisant les professions et
non plus les grandes catégories socio
professionnelles comme employés ouvriers
cadres supérieurs etc et ce nouveau
degré de précision dans la proche dans
l'analyse suffit pour créer une approche
originale et intéressante je dis suffis
mais il faut quand même le faire la
difficulté avec ce type de problématique
et que tu vas trouver beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'informations et ce sera très
compliqué pour bien sélectionner lecture
car il ya surabondance de travaux en
plus c'est un gros challenge parce que
être en mesure d'apporter un regard
original surtout si on est novice c'est
pas facile du tout
fuites à tes lectures tu peux aussi
constater qu'il existe des explications
différentes d'un même phénomène le cas
d'école et la confrontation des thèses
de bourdieu et de boudon quant aux
inégalités scolaires qui a raison d'un
point de vue empirique je sais que l'on
peut élargir ce type de problématique à
d'autres genres d'opposition par exemple
entre une théorie et les faits je me
souviens du thé feu d'une élève qui
avait construit une problématique
particulièrement intéressante on avait
étudié en classe la reproduction de
pierre bourdieu tu connais qui en gros
explique que l'origine sociale
conditionne fortement la scolarité d'un
élève à partir de ces leçons à l'avait
mis en tension la théorie de bourdieu et
des statistiques je crois que c'était
des statistiques personnelles qui
montrait que les trajectoires scolaires
peuvent être différentes pour des frères
et des soeurs ah oui on connaît tous des
enfants issus d'une même fratrie qui
n'ont pas les mêmes résultats à l'école
et qui d'ailleurs n'en prennent pas les
mêmes orientations alors l'effet
donne-t-il tort à bourdieu c'est ce
qu'elle voulait savoir et c'était
l'objet de son travail dans le même
ordre d'idée toute situation traversée
par un axe de tension peut se révéler
être une problématique intéressante
attention classique par exemple entre
sécurité et liberté
parfois on connaît l'existence d'un
phénomène ne peux pas l'expliquer le
phénomène est connu bien des cris
documenté mais jamais réellement
expliqué c'est une bonne problématique
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait dur km
avec son enquête sur le suicide à
l'époque on disposait de beaucoup de
statistiques sur les taux de suicide des
différentes catégories sociales et dans
les différentes régions mais personne
n'était en mesure d'expliquer les
variations des différents chiffres
pareils pour webber avant ces travaux on
savait que les capitalistes étaient plus
souvent en protestant que catholiques
mais on ne savait pas pourquoi donc à
chaque fois que l'on est confronté à un
traitement descriptive d'un phénomène
apporter une explication c'est à dire
répondre à la question pourquoi est
toujours une démarche pertinente et une
bonne problématique les quatre premiers
types de problématiques sont surtout des
problèmes empirique mais il peut
également être envisageable d'adopter
une problématique plus théorique
l'intérêt de certains travaux réside
surtout dans la construction d'un modèle
d' analyse cohérent et solide ou peut
par exemple tenter d'améliorer la
cohérence et les liens entre les
hypothèses ou clarifier les concepts
utilisés et correctement les définir ce
travail de construction ou de
reconstruction théorique est aussi très
judicieux mais il me semble que c'est
une tâche très lourde pour un élève et
ceux là doivent donc rester un genre de
problématique réservé aux chercheurs
plus aguerris mais ce n'est que mon avis
certaines études comportent des billets
ou des erreurs de méthodes qui peuvent
être discutés voir résolus dans un
nouveau travail
d'ailleurs certains chercheurs indiquent
parfois dans leur conclusion ce qui
aurait pu être fait autrement d'un point
de vue méthodologique
on pense par exemple à des choix de
méthodes d'observation d'échantillonnage
a des limites conjoncturels comme la
crise sanitaire qui empêche la bonne
tenue de l'observation et donc d'avoir
des résultats de recherche pleinement
satisfaisant d'ailleurs des études post
durkheimienne sur le suicide ont eu
comme unique problématique de rediscuter
des erreurs méthodologiques de l'oeuvre
de durkheim alors qu'il s'agit d'un
monument de la sociologie les
collectivités humaines doivent parfois
trouver des solutions à des problèmes
concrets
et sciences sociales peuvent proposer
des pistes d'action sur base de
nouvelles connaissances dégagée par une
recherche il se peut donc que tu
choisisses une problématique qui entend
contribuer à trouver une solution non
plus empirique ou théoriques mais bien
pratique ici l'enjeu est de savoir quoi
faire et comment faire face à une
situation déterminée par exemple une
recherche peut s'intéresser aux manières
de minimiser la phobie scolaire afin que
les écoles puissent lutter efficacement
contre ce problème qui menace la bonne
scolarité de certains élèves mais si je
peux donner mon avis je trouve qu'il
faut faire attention avec ce genre de
problématique car on arrive très vite
dans une approche normative où le
mélange des genres est une menace et
pour des élèves qui s'initient aux
sciences sociales cela peut être
compliqué à gérer ce qui n'est bien sûr
pas le cas pour les chercheurs les plus
expérimentés tu connais donc maintenant
les différents types de problématiques
envisageable pour ta recherche tu dois
bien avoir conscience qu'ils ne s'agit
ici que de modèles pour te donner des
idées et que dans la réalité des formes
hybrides ou nouvelles sont possibles
dans l'article à la base de cette vidéo
l'auteur andré gosselin donne les
résultats de l'observation qu'il a
réalisées sur base de 587 article de
sciences humaines et sociales que cela
soit en sociologie en sciences
politiques en communication ou en
économie l'absence de point de vue
nouveau et le type de problématique le
plus souvent privilégié je te mets bien
sûr le lien de l'article ci dessous afin
que tu puisses tout consulter en détail
et à ton aise malheureusement cette
étude date de 1900
une réactualisation de ce résultat
serait sans aucun doute une excellente
problématiques de recherche je te
remercie et je te dis à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]